for 85 year old cooler this winter has
been a road to recovery five months ago
she fell at her home in Cornwall and
broke her hip she lay on the cold floor
for 14 hours before an ambulance arrived
they said well we're just waiting for an
ambulance to free up to come to you and
where we don't know how long it's going
to be we are so busy
but getting an ambulance was only the
start getting into a e took even longer
how long in total did your mum have to
wait in the ambulance uh 26 hours
basically the ambulances in our waiting
rooms
because there's no room in the hospital
to take them there's no extra Wing
there's no bed space I was in disbelief
and I was like this can't be happening
how do you feel that you had to wait 40
hours to get into Hospital
it's scary it's more scary than anything
I would have been better die so many
hours
the Royal Cornwall Hospital offered its
sincere apologies to the family but
their story is not unique latest NHS
data analyzed by Sky News shows that on
average in the southwest ambulances had
to wait two hours and 39 minutes to hand
over patients to a e that's almost three
and a half times longer than the
national average
the target is 15 minutes the problem is
so bad here that the six NHS trusts with
the longest Handover times in the whole
of England are all in the Southwest
an older population spread remotely is
part of why things are so bad here the
hospitals in the southwest are under
such extreme pressure that in some cases
they've started to discharge patients
who are well enough into hotels usually
used by tourists in order to free up
some bed space
those being put in care hotels are well
enough to go home if there's some social
care available
one of the blockages coming out of
hospital is Community Care provision
social care so if there's no provision
in the community you can't get people
home if you can't get people home they
stay in hospital if they stay in
hospital there's a whole host of
challenges Associated to that hospital
acquired dependency the NHS told Sky
News delays in the southwest down to the
number of sick patients staffing issues
and delays discharging from hospital it
added we are working hard with
integrated care boards Hospital trusts
and our Ambulance Service to address
these delays and ensure patients are
handed over at hospitals in a timely way
coolers 40 hour wait is an extreme case
but it's an example of how the NHS in
the Southwest is struggling to cope
damn Whitehead Sky News in Cornwall